hello hello hello hello oh wait hold up
I'm trying to click that technology
right now oh here we go we're good now
what's up hey Adam yeah how's it going
buddy good so we're doing a special
episode on take-out food this is not
gonna be like a regular episode of worth
it because as you can see Steven and
Adam are not here in the car with me we
are observing all current requirements
for social distancing and we encourage
all of you to do the same stay home they
say so I'm gonna be picking up the food
today and dropping it off to Steven and
Adam so today I'm worth it we're gonna
be trying three different takeout menus
at three price points to find out how
they are all worth it
at their given price point these are all
restaurants and chefs that we've worked
with before they're doing some amazing
takeout food I love it i've missed worth
it I've been waiting for this moment you
know we haven't been able to eat at
restaurants but at the very least we can
take the restaurants to us so for our
first stop today we're gonna be visiting
the Kogi truck an LA institution the
Kogi truck is not a business that we've
filmed with before but we did film with
Roy Choi the chef/owner who was in our
brunch episode a few seasons back at the
place a frame we're going to the Kogi
truck to have their world-famous short
rib taco so the Kogi short rib taco is
Roy Choi's iconic taco he's taken Korean
flavors and put them into the tacos so
it's got short rib I believe a pickled
onion relish this red salsa that they
make themselves in this cabbage slaw so
imagine kind of like the taste of Korean
barbecue but in the format of a street
taco I mean I've had in a million
it's amazing it's an all-time great one
any worth a family I just want to say
thank you for supporting us and
highlighting Kogi during these tough
times man it's hard out here serving
this food and trying to stay alive but
doing it with you guys makes it worth it
oh sorry thank you all right
[Music]
by the way I'm on autofocus here Adam
woohoo it's always been good to me I
think the weirdest part about the way
that we're filming this is that we frame
the cameras it'll hey know where your
empty body is next to me yeah
even this is not where my dining table
usually is and I decided to include the
empty seat next to me as oh like a
heaven
sorry I didn't even do the car seat here
you can have that there and we got Adam
on the line directing us as always but
now he's right there on screen which is
a comforting sight do we do these
digging let's dig in
Adams got the kimchi quesadilla you want
to share that off whoo Adam have a very
nice saucing job also where'd you get
that plate how should we cheers do I
just do the I'm gonna choose no choose
your half of the screen yeah yeah yeah
three two one boom
[Music]
hmm Oh Adam can you all time is us now
yeah I don't have to hold the camera I
like this version of the show better
this that was incredible that was like a
perfect bite I feel like I haven't eaten
before it's been four weeks of gordy my
whole head is tingling I have like
chills after taking that buddy hmm is
that the vinaigrette that really just
rides at the top there I like that
mm-hmm you know just occurred to me that
I don't know that if I'm in focus at all
autofocus maybe remember two minutes ago
and I was like Adam your job is easy
despite the technical failures I'm
actually getting more emotional than I
anticipated like the feeling of eating a
restaurant food with your pals even if
it's over video chat like you know we've
we've done like what like six plus
seasons of worth it together
it's definitely hitting me right now
that like we for sure took for granted
all the time that we got to eat all
these delicious foods and meet these
people amazing people I'm very grateful
yeah you know it's great about this you
could instantly go take a nap there's
like no travel time you just get up go
over to the couch lights out
hello hello Steven all right day two
what are we doing today our next two
locations we're gonna have both of their
foods one after another gonna be kind of
like virtual dinner party so we're gonna
have a little pre-dinner drinks and
cheese and then we're gonna get this
family set from spoon by H you'll
remember from our Korean soup episode
Steven are you Steven are you drinking
an iced latte the ice
yeah I heard the ice Wow some things
will never change about making it no is
it matcha latte of course it is yeah
okay so the next place we're picking up
food from is Oh toto which is offering a
sake tasting set right now so you'll
remember Cortney and Charles from our
sushi and burger episode Oh Toto is this
sock a bar that also makes a lot
delicious savory food you're doing a
fried chicken dinner right now and
they're also doing this virtual sock a
school where you go and pick up a set of
sock a and then on the weekend they do a
live stream where you could learn about
what you're drinking and right now
they're doing a sake and cheese pairing
so that's what we're gonna have as our
happy hour before our dinner today I
can't tell you how happy I am to hear
this I know from you Andrew I know that
you love sucking and cheese is a guilty
pleasure for me only because Canada they
handle dairy very well but I'm at home I
can use the bathroom whenever I want and
so no problemo hey guys welcome to the
dinner party thank you there's nobody
here to tell me my collars messed up or
I'm wearing shorts right now with this
jacket I don't know if that's a good or
appropriate but yeah does everybody have
their worksheet you got two sakhis and
two cheeses um wait let me get you
sitting like in the zone and the mood
real quick I'm just gonna like imagine
I'll go throw in my head okay I'm at the
bar
you had the cat coaster that's
underneath there's great chopsticks
oh great chopsticks and there's there's
a shelf of sake over there okay I'm good
in the zone first lucky today we're
gonna taste the sock they call crudité
shape because she translates to black
bull or black cow cheese pub pre-ops
either out a triple cream French cow's
milk cheese with a bloomie rind but all
of the successful pairing is for both to
taste better the sake hopefully tastes
good on its own cheese tastes good on
its own then you put them together and
they both
though I don't know if this is super
common knowledge but as a cake comes in
these little pop top glass jars which i
think is just fantastic I actually have
a fun show and tell to go with this so
when we went to Japan remember we went
to Nikko yeah so we went to this grocery
store where what did we buy there we
bought the bento yeah the bento historic
trains were a big part of Nikko
so I actually bought a jar of sake at
the time that has the old-timey train on
it that's cool and I've used this as
like my at home wine glass ever since Oh
Adams got one flavor
what Oh interesting oh I should change
the name to couch oh sure
I'll see myself out of my own apartment
cheers Cheers
oh yeah very smooth whoa
all right let's pet unpack this cheese
oh it's extremely moist whoa
it looks like a happy and ice-cream
sandwich whoa and now this okay
oh okay whoa moussaka definitely helps
with the funk the one thing about this
sheets are just so unique is how creamy
it is it's like almost custardy how it's
good but that opened my mind up okay so
moving on to Saki and cheese number two
the next sake we have is a parade called
a mabuki this one the team already uses
sunflower East for me it's less floral
it's more sort of nutty like almost a
sunflower
and it's an AMA so unpasteurized keeps a
little bit more brightness in Lusaka it
also kind of turns the aromatics up when
you pasteurized sake it mellows things
out it rounds it but it can sort of
soften it we're gonna pair that with a
cheese called very go which is a goat's
milk cheese from New Jersey
it is a natural rind and it is caving
whoa let's go steak straight-up opposite
of the other cheese it almost looks like
the crust of bread kind of rye so we're
going from a creamy cheese with a creamy
sake to a nutty sake with a funky cheese
- okay it smells like Stillwater think I
have so much cheese in my moustache that
I can't smell anything I'm mad
you wanna do Sokka a cheese oh yeah oh
wow wow I like it yeah I love that one
that's the cheese I like it's grainy and
it's funky man it's grainy and funky
once again you put them together and it
absolutely sings I really like the rhyme
adds a nice bitter taste that rounds out
the cheese it's like a good ending hey
Adam yeah your shirt matches the
cross-stitch behind you that's a second
sake observation so next we'll be having
spoon by H and spoon by H is a Korean
dessert cafe that also does amazing
savory food it's an ever-changing menu
there's different stuff that you can get
during the week like right now they have
an amazing lunch box
that's called a dosa rack I'm not sure
how to pronounce that Eun has come up
with this amazing family pack of entrees
desserts and appetizers that we're gonna
be enjoying next that's available
currently on weekends and so we're gonna
do a sampling of each of the things
offered this week and probably pack away
and save much of this to eat over the
course of the coming week because this
is a lot of it
hello with it thanks for stopping by you
guys are trying our family path which is
a changing menu of some of our favorite
dishes so this is what's on the menu
this week macaroni salad M cheek cold
pasta salad honey garlic toast
vegetarian curry braised chicken legs
and radish peanut noodles kimchi fried
rice beef short rib rice cake soup
vegetarian miso ramen sue maple honey
walnut muffin in iced tea
I see there's cheers let's go max Alex
gross macaroni salad Oh using your uh
I'm Bob bull I am humble nice I'm but
bowl I'm using a bowl that I used to
feed cats mmm it's crab in here yeah
this is what the heck
so it's actually crab macaroni salad
well the spam in here too like I was
under sold as just macaroni salad but
it's really like 50% brand next day I
forgot kimchi cold pasta salad I'm not
gonna lie I was not expecting this pasta
shape what is this penne Wow oh man Kim
she loves to party with vehicles explain
yourself sir
Kim she just wants a vehicle like pasta
vehicle for the kimchi kimchi quesadilla
Adam had at Kogi it wants carbs and fats
to ride on cuz it's a powerful flavor
next up we have the honey garlic toast
yeah it's this thick thick slice of what
seems to be brioche looks cartoony it
really does a toast to the toast toast
I'm gonna go this way on my camera who I
don't know to tell us that I'm toast
yeah
what a mess this is hey this is like if
there was a garlic bread jelly beans yes
because it tastes slightly sweet but it
is a garlic right
I would not expect honey to belong on a
garlic bread it's very delicious now to
what I've been looking forward to the
most actually vegetarian curry I love
curry ok this egg is beautiful this is a
beautiful curry I think I think he's
just trying to like how do all the
episodes we have ever done before
yeah she's like toast got it garlic
bread salad boom
macaroni salad + crab oh yeah next up we
got braised chicken leg gonna pick up a
chicken leg mmm
what you know I can order I get it I get
it you feel like what she tries to do
with these meals is like you think you
know what you gonna get like you're like
yeah Oh chicken and radish but no it's
like how can I make this dish as
different as what you expect it to be as
possible next the peanut noodles reminds
me of a don don man Wow such a meaty
peanut your dog that's good man yeah
it's that peanut plus meat flavor is
usually you think peanut butter jelly
peanut plus sweet
here they go you know close meat ok
kimchi fried rice can I actually try
pants what happened Steven oh you can
change your pants but this is going in
the episode if you do you got the kimchi
fried rice it's really almost like
risotto more than fried rice gets of the
cap it off we have the miso ramen and
then we have the short rib soup I say we
freeze and save that one for later and
we eat a miso ramen for now that's a
good plan it looks like there's a
instructions here to cook the noodles
and then stick them in when we're ready
great dish to round out the meal with
how'd your ramen come out okay not
really good yeah that's great
final dish
hmm oh man oh yeah I see - you're gonna
compliment myself on the al dente pasta
Thank You Steven this is finishing the
meal on a strong punch the noodles are
very good they're very chewy MS broth
probably the most flavorful thing we've
eaten yet this is what I like to call
Desert noodles oh we have a muffin maple
honey walnut muffins
[Music]
that is a moist muffin Oh baby I came
down well that does it boys that's the
end of our worth it takeout adventure
we're not gonna be picking a worth it
winter today because we think all these
restaurants are really worth it like we
always do and really we just want to
encourage people to support their local
businesses that they really love like we
really love these three places right now
especially you can order pickup or
delivery all of them are still open have
a virtual dinner party the shape of this
noodle does a really good job of
grabbing all the flavor I like cat's
tongue I don't know if you're familiar
with the anatomy of a pet stop I'm very
familiar its texture to brush a fur of
the cat little ridges much like this
noodle pick up this stuff